oui avec Nicole Kidman
non Nicole Kinder
je l'avais vu à Cannes lors du festival
à la soirée on avait eu un échange de
regard et elle m'a inspiré parce que je
sais j'étais à Cannes à l'époque ah ben
voilà j'étais avec parce que j'étais
avec des potes j'étais avec des potes de
Nadia merci
et on a eu un appel et Nicole qui m'a
disait qu'elle avait croisé un petit
copain
oui et après j'ai rêvé d'elle j'étais
déguisé en druide de Gaulois dans la
forêt de Brocéliande en Bretagne et je
la poursuivrai en levant ma cape oh oui
à vous mais
Tom Cruise il faisait mission impossible
il s'est mission pas possible c'est pas
possible non non
Bretagne
c'est un rêve je t'explique oui mais non
je te le dis oui mon fantasme c'est
Cardi B j'aime bien
je connais très bien en fait elle
s'appelle Josiane tibi
je te jure
des Tournelles
mais comment elle est venu sur ma
voiture
[Rires]
c'est vrai que ça nous change de Justin
Bieber c'est Justin Bieber salut
et toi la je connais moi non mais non
on était là alors on était à sa villa le
lac de du lac de Côme qui est sublime
j'étais dans une sorte de petit peignoir
un peu un une sorte de déshabiller
c'est là qu'il écrit la chanson Aïcha
mais quoi bien sûr comme si
[Applaudissements]
dans le lac tous les deux c'est toujours
chiant
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
je me suis pris une méduse je peux te
dire que ça fait très mal
je connais qui vous a piqué la Méduse
[Rires]
avec vous
non érotique en fait vous êtes je vous
surprends avec ma femme ah ouais alors
non alors c'est pas vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
de quelqu'un oui je rêve de Dani dalgo
mais depuis que je suis parti de Paris
c'est dans un cocktail à la municipalité
à l'hôtel de ville elle me coin c'est le
mode traîne dans les toilettes et
montre-moi ton gros rat montre-moi ton
gros rat
[Applaudissements]
vous avez le même rêve érotique que moi
quoi alors moi il y a quelques années
j'ai filmé Serena Williams à
Roland-Garros et le soir de mon film en
fait j'ai rêvé que j'étais avec elle
dans les dans les vestiaires dans les
douches avec le L1 corps subit enfin moi
j'arrive sublime
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'allais acheter des meubles dans les
chiottes
et dans le même magasin de meubles il y
avait serré là Williams
avec un gars son mari certainement
j'étais en train de se galoche
et elle a été aux toilettes
je suis passé après
je peux vous dire
c'était super
[Rires]
trous noirs
c'était Patrick moraton
je jouais sur un cours et qui arrive sur
mon cours Djokovic
il vient pour prendre mon cours j'ai dit
non vous avez réservé monsieur
tu reviens à midi
on a rigolé après il a joué avec moi et
donc
c'est un mec on a rigolé après depuis et
à chaque jour après on se voyait là-bas
et en fait c'est déprimant de jouer à
côté de Djokovic et il était toujours
sympathique à chaque fois la fin
d'entraînement il me dit bah viens jouer
un peu avec nous
il est super sympa du coup Delphine
moi un rêve avec une star mais en fait
c'est une femme
j'ai rêvé et je me souviens de ce rêve
c'était avec Lady Di en fait on a passé
une soirée ensemble et en fait elle m'a
expliqué pendant toute la soirée son
œuvre comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
arriver voilà
ce qu'elle a fait de sa vie en ce
moment-là
mais vraiment elle est vraiment
inspirante et donc du coup j'ai rêvé
d'elle qu'elle m'a expliqué tout ce
qu'elle a fait de sa vie
à mon avis
[Rires]
scandale derrière je faisais l'amour
avec Delphine non et on dit rien elle
m'appelle quelques semaines après elle
me dit je suis enceinte non
[Rires]
bloque tout pour l'instant tout ce qui
est photo il m'est arrivé la même chose
avec Daniel
donc on a emmerdé vis-à-vis de la chaîne
non mais si tu veux la chaîne est
content d'avoir mais c'est génial alors
elle veut garder elle veut garder parce
que c'est mannequin
bon bah toi c'est compliqué l'argent
et encore avant
je comprends je comprends pas
savoir ça m'a fait bizarre que tu
traverses ma mère qui confirme c'est
vrai pour Djoko j'ai la photo
[Applaudissements]
elle vous évite
je m'en fous c'est votre fils qui fait
la table
et Daniel et Daniel elle prit tous les
jours pour toi
faut que le PSG gagne
[Applaudissements]